wenn wir die zahlen nähmen auch die
entwicklung heute brauchen wir
eigentlich noch mal 10 14 tage
mindestens richtiges runterfahren
unseres unserer kontakte unserer
mobilität lockdown wenn sie so nennen
wollen so wie wir es letztes jahr ostern
ja auch erlebt haben ich würde auch
gerne vermeiden wollen nochmal an ostern
wie letztes jahr ich wäre auch lieber
mit der familie im großen kreis aber es
geht halt dieses jahr noch nicht
nicht zuletzt wegen der britischen
mutationen oder die die wir britische
mutation männer wegen der
ansteckungsfälle ich kai pfundt und wenn
wir diese welle brechen würden
miteinander rechtzeitig idealerweise
bevor sie zu groß wird im april dann
könnten wir anschließend genau diese
öffnung schritte gehen die wir jetzt in
städten in regionen mit niedriger
incidents wie in tübingen ja jetzt schon
sehen also es gibt ja die modelle die
zeigen ist kann gehen aber voraussetzung
ist natürlich dass wir das
infektionsgeschehen erstmal unter
kontrolle wieder kriegen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaue ich je das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren